der ende asperges par dizaines des
vertes des violettes des blanches caché
dans le sable nous sommes à saint thomas
petit coin de campagne entre joliette et
le grand centre d'enfouissement de la
compagnie eb
on a peut-être 5 6 km maximum
cela fait douze ans que mario rondeau
fait sortir des asperges de ses terres
fall à dorloter
mais après nous donner beaucoup si on
fait attention avec les années la seule
eau sont quasiment après demain ils vont
être près de certains ces deux là et ces
deux là comme les autres
elles se nourrissent de st le chimiste
et philosophe lavoisy et l'a résumé rien
ne se perd rien ne se crée tout se
transforme
mais pour que tous les restes de table
se transforme en fertilisant il ya des
progrès à faire dans le compostage à
l'horaire
taux de récupération en 2016 20% alors
que l'objectif était de 60 % en 2015
la clé pour débloquer les mentalités
encore et toujours la sensibilisation
je pense qu'on a vu les ca sont
semblables car on avait planté le reste
là je sais à montréal c'est quelque
chose qui prend du temps à mettre en
place une nouvelle d'apprendre il y en a
tout de même qu'ils prennent la
situation très à coeur nos poubelles
depuis lé 16 novembre sept mois de
consommation et zéro déchet ou presque
c'est leur mode de vie et une fois que
quand on a une haine bac brun ça a tout
réglé on a pu descendre la poubelle aux
seules les matières organiques
représentent la moitié des déchets
ramassés au québec
regardons les données pour les 15
arrondissements du secteur est de
montréal en moyenne sur les six derniers
mois de 2010 est il y avait près de 7 kg
de compost chaque mois dans les bacs de
côte des neiges ou dan sic mais presque
deux fois moins dans l'arrondissement du
sud ouest
au total l'année dernière on a récupéré
20 mille tonnes de compost dans l'est de
la ville
l'équivalent de froid fils in olympiques
mais il en faudrait le double pour
atteindre les objectifs les gens
comprennent mal ce qu'il se passe avec
le compost les matières organiques on en
voit qu'on collecte explique mal alors
voici ce qui se passe pour l'est de
montréal
une fois le bac récupérer course les
camions font un premier arrêt à montréal
est transbordement dans de plus grands
camions qui file à 60 kilomètres de là
un trajet de 45 minutes pour aller
déverser sur le site de compostage de
pays à saint-thomas un voisin qui rend
service à mario rondot c'est là qu'ils
achètent le compost pour ses asperges à
25 dollars la tonne la compass garde
l'humidité en plus en plus d'apporter
des apports de nutriments mais ça aide
aussi à garder l'humidité pour
l'appelant vous boucler une boucle parce
que vous fertiliser le sol qui va
produire des asperges qui à produire la
nourriture avec des restes de nourriture
à ce jour à montréal
87% des huit logements et moins ont leur
bac
ce sera 100 % l'année prochaine
reste à équiper les plus grands
immeubles et les institutions et aussi à
lever les réticences surtout les t1 va
mettre nos déchets organiques dans le
congélateur
donc quand ils viennent ça fait un pot
qui est propre mais un bloc dans les
bacs bruns une technique certes radicale
mais qui porte ses fruits il minnesota
les mots j'en ai jamais eu de problème
de mouches à fruits ou de verre
pendant qu'à l'autre bout du chemin du
compost le cycle de l'aspergent touche à
sa fin pour la saison ici mathieu prost
radio-canada saint thomas
[Musique]